your hand is so great you don't have a
dot on your nose yes i know that i do
because i had it no you know what it is
have you ever had the older brother the
little brother situation go on where
like you know like one guy can just
smash the other and let they just keep
going at it no that that thing on your
nose
it's [ __ ] from kissing fighter's ass
that's what it is you know the thing on
your nose is careful [ __ ] okay if i just
want to be real you hear me i like to be
real okay but they're carrying on you're
not gonna get mad
the dermatologist said stop kissing fire
our boy cody garbrandt he's fighting
i got i got my car in france when i come
back to this i want to come back
you shut up
[Laughter]
i'm a little sensitive about my [ __ ]
like burn you know what's sensitive what
fighter's [ __ ] when you kiss them
for the [ __ ] no no i'm not gonna
nah the photo [ __ ]
you